what was it like working with Ed Whitton
who uh many people say is one of the
smartest
humans in history
or at least mathematical physicists in
history yes fascinating I enjoy I
enjoyed it very much I also felt they
have to keep up you know and uh so we
wrote this long paper and until 2007 and
we collaborated for about a year
I have known him before and we talked
before and because I've seen him since
and we talked but it's very different to
just meet somebody at conferences and
have a conversation
as opposed to actually working on the
project together
so he is very very very very serious
very focused this is one thing which I
have to say I was really struck by this
why is he considered to be
such a powerful intellect by many other
powerful attacks
he had uh he has had this unique vision
of the subject he was able to connect
different things
uh especially
find connections between quantum physics
and Mathematics
almost unparalleled I don't think anyone
comes close in some sense in the last
uh you know 50 years to him in terms of
finding just consistently time after
time breaking around new ground new
ground so it it would basically one way
one could describe it is
it would take some idea in physics
and and then
find an interpretation of it in
mathematics
and then say distill it present it in
mathematical terms and tell
mathematicians this should be like that
you know kind of like one plus two plus
three plus four is minus 1 over 12. I
imagine should be like no way
and then
it would pan out and mathematicians
would then like like a whole industry
would be created of
groups of mathematicians trying to prove
his conjectures and his ideas and he
would always be proven right you know so
in other words being able to glean some
mathematical truths from
um physical theories that's one side on
the other hand
conversely applying sophisticated
mathematics as he is probably
uh
the physicist who kind of could learn
mathematics the fastest I don't think
some younger faces maybe could come
close but it's still quite for them a
long way to go to to get you know to be
comparable to whiten
to take some of the most sophisticated
mathematics
and not learn it to the point where it
becomes a practitioner of the subject
practically
and then use it to
gain some new insights on the physics
side now of course the thing is that the
theory is that physics one could say is
an assault of a crisis in some sense
because of a current gap between the
sophisticated
theories which came from applying
sophisticated mathematics and the actual
universe
so we have theories first which describe
10-dimensional worlds 10 dimensional
space-time coming from string theory and
things like that
but we don't know yet how to
apply it to understanding our universe
a lot of progress has been made but it's
kind of a at a kind of impasse right now
and at the same time the our most
realistic theories most advanced
theories of the four-dimensional
universe are in contradiction with each
other
and the standard model describing the
three known forces of nature the
electromagnetic strong and weak
to lose great accuracy and Einstein's
relativity which describes the fourth
called gravity
everybody everybody
above a certain age knows that one
yeah
so these two theories are in
contradiction at the moment and string
theory was one of the at the promise of
Sting theory was that it would unify
those two and so far it has not has not
happened so we are kind of at a very
interesting place right now and uh I
think that new ideas perhaps are needed
and I I wouldn't be surprised if Wheaton
is one of those people who come up with
those ideas well he has been one of the
one of the people that added a lot of
ideas under the flag of string theory